ein tesla mit 160 stundenkilometern
mitten in berlin
jetzt hat sozusagen seinen eigenen
fahrer das ist
vier kameras zwei zur seite eine vorn
eine hinten
im zweiten robusten übersandte uns die
firma tesla einen zugang in deren cloud
der test hat auf jeden fall als antennen
genauso wie den händen
[Musik]
berlin juni 2009 10 eine kreuzung in
tempelhof ein tesla
und dieses motorrad
es kommt mit 140 stundenkilometern von
rechts schlägt in die seite des tesla
ein der film das mit seiner seiten
kamera
der motorradfahrer überschlägt sich in
der luft er wird schwer verletzt das
filmt der tesla mit seiner front kamera
beide aufnahmen hier in zeitlupe sendet
der wagen an den server der tesla
verwaltung in amsterdam
hier ist das alles passiert
andreas winkelmann ist amtsanwalt und
damals beteiligt an der
unfallermittlungen erfolgt nach fahnder
hatten bei tesla mit einwilligung des
tesla fahrers und bekommt die videos was
dann kam hat uns extrem überrascht am
zweiten august übersandte uns die firma
tesla einen zugang in deren cloud und
link kann man sagen und über diesen link
konnten wir dann
zwei videos ziehen von der front und der
seiten kamera die das unfallgeschehen im
detail offenbaren wie die schuld des
eigentlichen beschuldigten dieses
testfahrers wesentlich herabgesenkt
haben was tesla aufnimmt und wo
speichert das versuchen fred blüthner
und sein chef jürgen bönninger von der
firma fahrzeugsystem daten in radeberg
herauszufinden die firma recherchiert
unter anderem für tüv oder dekra wie die
moderne autoelektronik geprüft werden
blüthner zeigt uns die tesla kameras die
kamera sitzen hier oben ja hinter diesem
bereich mehr beheizt es die seiten
kameras setzen einerseits in der b-säule
name hier vorne am kotflügel noch eine
kamera genauso auch auf der anderen
seite die den rückwärtigen bereich
entdeckt und die letzte kamera sitzt im
heck
das ist die nahbereichs kamera die sitzt
die unter dem tesla logo das ist genau
dieser kleine rubel hier unten ja
ein usb stick in der mittelkonsole
eingesteckt jetzt kann der sogenannte d
scan modus aktiviert werden er zeichnet
die fahrt auf aber auch bilder von
unbeteiligten passanten
anlasslose dauerhaftes auszeichnen ist
in deutschland aber nicht erlaubt
erklärt der bayerische
datenschutzbeauftragte michael will
zuständig für beschwerden über tesla wir
haben im datenschutzrecht
alltäglich fallgestaltungen zu behandeln
wo menschen in ihren autos kameras mit
sich führen fortlaufend aufnahmen des
verkehrsgeschehens machen das führt bei
uns immer wieder zu bußgeldverfahren
wenn die polizei solche vorgänge
entdeckt tesla reicht die verantwortung
ganz ohne käufer weiter in der
bedienungsanleitung heißt es
sie sind für die einhaltung aller
örtlich geltenden gesetze vorschriften
und urheberrechtsschutz beschränkungen
in bezug auf videoaufzeichnungen
verantwortlich
doch in diesem fall warum die bilder
nicht im auto gespeichert sondern auf
dem server
besser kann die bilder die er filmt auch
theoretisch auf den server senden da
kann die nicht nur theoretisch auf dem
server senden wenn man als nutzer
zustimmt dann werden die sogar mit
absicht zum server gesendet und wie
sendet der tesla die daten der sendet
die einfach über eine sim karte eine
mobilfunkverbindung
die im auto fest verbaut ist und die zu
einem tesla auch dazu gehört die videos
vom server haben den tesla fahrer bei
diesem unfall entlastet
[Musik]
es kann aber auch ganz anders kommen
berlin januar 2020 prenzlauer allee ecke
karlstraße
ein tesla rast kurz nach mitternacht mit
über 160 stundenkilometern auf diese
kreuzung zu kriegt die kurve nicht
knallt auf die ampel als die polizei
eintrifft ist der fahrer weg
fahrerflucht
doch das tesla frack sendet unterdessen
dass -unfall video zum server
dazu die sekunden genauen details der
irrsinns fahrt über vier minuten
geschwindigkeit
gaspedalstellung
beschleunigung
bremsmanöver unfall ereignis
frontal legt die übermittelte datei den
radeberger experten vor diese in diese
protokolle zum ersten mal und sind
überrascht das verwundert tatsächlich
das ist über vier minuten hier eine
datenaufzeichnung gab weil
normalerweise man ungefähr 15 sekunden
vor dem unfall ereignisse und noch mal
zehn sekunden nach dem unfall ereignis
etwas aufzeichnet und das deutet darauf
hin dass auch ohne unfall daten
weitergegeben werden und das sind
natürlich kritisch dass tesla wrack
filmt unterdessen weiter auch die
bergung und speichert sie auf der
festplatte im fahrzeug
auf dieser festplatte finden die
ermittler später auch noch die bilder
des geflohenen fahrers
und seiner beifahrerin
kurz vor antritt der unfallfahrt
wir haben eine videoaufzeichnung vom
fahrverhalten ist angeklagt wir haben
genau auskunft darüber wie tief ins
gaspedal getreten worden sind schnell
das fahrzeug war wird es laut sagen
fahrer überführt der fahrer hat
sozusagen seinen eigenen fahrer
verschiffen er hat ihn verraten
ansonsten wäre die aufklärung dieser tat
in dieser breite in dieser tiefe nicht
möglich gewesen aus den tesla daten geht
hervor dass der fahrer nach dem crash
immer wieder vollgas gab nachfrage der
ermittler bei tesla ergebnis der mann
hatte wohl erfolglos versucht weiter zu
fahren die fahrertür öffnete erst 48
sekunden nach dem crash die beifahrertür
mehr als eine minute danach tesla wusste
dass auch monate später auf die sekunde
genau und lieferte die daten
das bedeutet aber dass tesla sogar weiß
wann ich meine türen aufmachen das ist
absurd anzunehmen denn tesla hat uns
ganz genau den kunden zeitpunkt
geliefert waren die rechte fahrzeugtür
und wann die linke fahrzeugtür nach
dieser diesem crash detection nach
dieser crash meldung gemeldet worden
sind teslas kameras können nicht nur zum
filmen der fahrt genutzt werden sondern
auch im geparkten zustand im sogenannten
wächter modus dann nehmen sie jeden auf
der sich dem fahrzeug nähert in diesem
fall uns während des interviews
hier sehen wir erst mal den wächter
modus ansicht der verwendet vier kameras
zwei zur seite eine vorn eine hinten die
sind auch relativ hoch auflösend das
heißt wenn personen darauf zu sehen sind
sind auch auf jeden fall auch die
gesichter zu erkennen wir sehen dass
jetzt auch auf den verschiedenen kameras
dass wir uns jetzt sehr nah am fahrzeug
aufgehalten haben und hier hat das
fahrzeug also entschieden das speichern
war jetzt ab landen auch unsere bilder
auf dem testserver wenn sich der käufer
einverstanden erklärt so die
datenschutzerklärung von tesla sendet
das fahrzeug im vichter modus die mit
ihrer fahrgestellnummer verknüpften
videoaufnahmen zur vorübergehenden
speicherung an tesla
informationen die rückschlüsse auf die
identität des käufers zu lassen kann
tesla an dritte übertragen und
offenlegen so die datenschutzerklärung
wenn wir in gutem glauben der ansicht
sind dass dies rechtlich vorgeschrieben
ist in beantwortung einer rechtmäßigen
anfrage von staatlichen behörden
oder um die rechte und das eigentum von
tesla und dritten zu schützen
was wir ausschließlich nach unserem
eigenen ermessen bestimmen
es genügt schon alleine das tetzlaff in
der lage sind jeden der ihnen nahe kommt
zu überwachen und zwar unabhängig davon
ob danach mit dem auto etwas geschieht
oder nicht es genügt um
datenschutzrechtliche fragen aufzuwerfen
dass diese daten dann an ein unternehmen
weitergeleitet werden dass damit dinge
tut die nicht wirklich klar sind und
über die der gefilmte keinerlei
entscheidungen
der fahrzeugkäufer können der
datenerfassung widersprechen allerdings
mit schwerwiegenden folgen
dies kann dazu führen dass bei ihrem
fahrzeug eine lediglich eingeschränkte
funktionalität ernsthafte schäden oder
funktionsunfähigkeit eintreten
unter diesen umständen
werden die meisten tesla käufer die
daten wohl freigeben
es ist deshalb nicht richtig wenn
alleine einer das ist meist der
fahrzeughalter überall diese datenströme
entscheidet denn er verfügt damit
genauso über die daten von irgendeinem
späteren fahrzeugführer wie über die
daten von passanten das alles ist nicht
seine verfügungsbefugnis und insoweit
überschreitet er seine
datenschutzrechtlichen befugnisse sie
gehören in keinem fall tesla tesla
erlangt überhaupt erst zugang und
nutzungsmöglichkeiten zu den daten auf
grundlage der jetzt unter verschiedenen
gesichtspunkten sehr sehr angreifbar
nutzungsbestimmungen
ein interview will tesla nicht geben
schriftlich erklärt die firma
kategorisch zitat aufnahmen durch die
desg m und den wächter modus werden
unter keinen umständen an tesla
übertragen
allerdings würden 30 sekündige
frequenzen bei sicherheitskritischen
ereignissen oder nach ausdrücklicher
zustimmung des kunden automatisch
gespeichert und konnten abgerufen werden
weiter erklärt tesla hat sie dort zum
schutz der privatsphäre liegen die
fahrzeugdaten standardmäßig anonymisiert
vor
in einer reihe von sonderfällen
personenbezogene daten speichere tesla
nur so lange wie erforderlich
wenn test ein vertrauenswürdiges
unternehmen ist dann ist fast alles
möglich dann können sie die komplette
umgebung alle personen alle
verkehrsteilnehmer alle fahrzeuge alle
objekte hier
klar identifizieren und könnten das auch
in einem land in dem keine
rechtsstaatlichkeit vorherrscht können
sie das auch zur überwachung der
menschen und der bevölkerung mit
einsetzen also das heißt man kann im
grunde nur darauf die integrität dieses
unternehmens setzen ich hoffe dass das
wir darauf setzen können und dass die
fahrzeuge nicht in einer diktatur dazu
genutzt
ermittler winkelmann hat allerdings auch
daten von tesla bekommen ohne dass es
überhaupt einen unfall gab
berliner stadtautobahn a100
höchstgeschwindigkeit 80
stundenkilometer oder weniger einen
tesla und ein motorrad wenn gleichzeitig
geblitzt das heißt fahrzeug wurde mit
einer geschwindigkeit von etwa 206
zentimeter geblitzt da bestand der
verdacht des kraftfahrzeug grenzt dass
wir bei der firma tesla nachgehakt haben
wo zu diesem fahrzeug
digitale fahrzeugdaten vorhanden sind
dem war auch so der tesla firmencomputer
liefert die belege für das rennen folge
strafverfahren für den tesla fahrer der
prozess läuft nun
in diesem fall gab es ja nicht mal ein
unfall ereignet es gab in diesem fall
keine crash meldung an tesla es gab
keinen
vereinbarten waren auf dem server von
der firma tesla obwohl es kein unfall
war
fazit tesla autos können menschen filmen
denen sie begegnen menschen die den
geparkten autos nahe kommen
möglicherweise in kompromittierenden
situationen
menschen die mit tesla nie einen vertrag
abgeschlossen haben können auf den
servern von tesla landen ohne es zu
wissen